un scientifique qui vient de nous qui
viennent nous parler de son domaine
d'excellence
alors aujourd'hui c'est un dispositif un
petit peu particulier
d'abord parce que j'ai eu des galères
techniques donc j'ai plein de fils
partout j'ai l'impression d'être dans l'
iss j'espère que malgré ça ça va bien se
passer mais finalement ça tombe pas si
mal parce que les ss vous verrez on va
en parler un petit peu tout à l'heure
d'une façon assez inattendue mais tout
nantes
nos invités du jour on est sur les
starting blocks comme dit mon éminent
confrère fabrice l'ico qui m'a
aimablement prêté cette plaisanterie je
suis évidemment avec la grande spéciale
une des meilleures spécialistes
mondiales
il faut le dire clairement audrey
dussutour audrey dussutour vous êtes
biologiste vous êtes directrice de
recherche au cnrs travailler à toulouse
à l'université paul sabatier
vous êtes alors là c'est de là que vous
allez nous pour répondre à propos du
blog je dis tout de suite que vous êtes
l'auteur de ce livre
voilà qui est la bible blog tout ce que
vous avez toujours sur le blog sans
jamais oser le demander
c'est un livre qui est vraiment super
d'abord parce que il porte bien son nom
on peut tout savoir sur le blog mais
d'une façon plus inattendue pour moi ça
raconte plein de choses sur la façon
dont ce fait la science ça parle des
publications scientifiques ça parle de
la pression sur les chercheurs ça parle
de la nécessité de publier et au travers
de l'exemple du blog audrey dussutour
vos données à vous or là la recherche
d'aujourd'hui donc c'est vraiment
passionnant
on est aussi avec une invitée qu'on
connaît bien sûr s'élève à venir parce
que elle a travaillé avec nous à la
rédaction c'est valentine delattre
valentina jours on va en dire un petit
peu plus sur toi tout de suite parce que
évidemment le monde entier c'est à dire
les lecteurs de télérama aux auditeurs
de france inter tu connais c'est un
chêne à chaîne youtube a un qui
s'appelle de comptoir c'est une superbe
la voilà voilà on va loger au pied
évidemment bon alors moi je suis olivier
lascars rédacteur en chef du numérique à
sciences et avenir et on valentin kolia
journalistes si la science et avenir
community manager c'est valentin qui
gère d'une main de maître
nos réseaux sociaux notre page facebook
twitter instagram linkedin on est
absolument partout et c'est lui aussi
qui pianote sur son clavier pour faire
la régie de ce direct sur twitter alors
il va nous montrer un petit extrait
rapide au delà des programmes sur
science de comptoir sciences de comptoir
ça parle de cailloux valentine oui
essentiellement de cailloux de géologie
alors on aura l'occasion d'évoquer c'est
un peu plus tard dans l'émission parce
que valentine tu va nous raconter tout à
l'heure comment toi et battus à élever
un blog j'allais dire dans ta cuisine
s'est pas totalement vrai parce que tu
l'a même élevé dans la rédaction de
sciences et avenir c'était pour les
besoins d'un papier ou n'en parlera tout
à l'heure alors bonjour à tous parce que
vous êtes déjà un paquet à nous regarder
vous êtes près d'un millier déjà bonjour
à coelacanthe bonjour à alex cam 29-23
c'est très compliqué très stimulant les
pseudos sur twitch il faut avoir les
curieux dans la bouche pour les
prononcer le guépard cette brise au
bonjour à tous
alors audrey dussutour on l'a dit vous
êtes spécialiste du globe
on en parle beaucoup depuis quelques
années le succès médiatique du globe est
important mais néanmoins bon il y en a
peut-être qui ont raté les premiers les
premiers épisodes et qui savent pas ce
que c'est qu'un blog alors pour rentrer
dans le sujet on va l'être une petite
séquence de film mais c'est pas
forcément le film auquel vous vous
attendez valentin tu peux nous envoyer
la séquence
alors c'est un film des années des
années 80 c'est un film qui donne à voir
un personnage
auquel je pense moi à chaque fois quand
quand il est question du club
c'est une star wars par mel brooks la
petite review dre dussutour ça s'appelle
la folle histoire de l'espace et donc là
il ya un personnage qui est une
ques et une parodie de jabba le hutt ils
l'ont appelé pizza hut et est alors moi
à chaque fois qu'on me parle du blog ans
à lui d'ailleurs il faut que je retrouve
la couverture de votre livre voilà et
alors sur la couverture de votre livre
voilà alors c'est vraiment lui alors en
plus en plus ce qui est super dans le
bouquin c'est que vous avez tout fait de
a à z c'est vous qui avez fait les
dessins aussi alors je sais pas si le
bloc de couverture et vous aussi
il a passé le seuil clé pour celui-là il
pas de vous et chaque fois je pensais
alors qu audrey dussutour le blob
c'est un organisme qui est très très
particulier parce que déjà il est
constitué que d'une seule cellule où est
exactement ça fait une cellule kg an
puisqu'elle peut atteindre jusqu'à 10
mètres carrés donc ça c'est le record
est enregistrée au business des records
donc cédé la boue des laborantins vise à
faire le bloc le plus grand possible
était dix mètres carrés mais ils ont
arrêté parce qu'ils sont arrêtées là
ils sont arrivés à la limite du blog
mais parce que ça prenait beaucoup de
travail je nourrirais alors que des
internautes qui sont bien renseignés sur
la question la capitaine younis plein
qui a dû cas du lag dans ça peut-être
être corrigé il nous dit c'est encore un
coup du fise arômes polycéphale umf visa
rom polycéphale où mme audrey dussutour
c'est son nom scientifique
c'est sûrement l'atteindre tout à fait
on n'avait pas de nom commun en français
hier il en existe à en anglais on ne
l'avait pas nous et donc gelé surnommé
le blob et c'est rentré dans big o
maintenant on peut tous la paix le globe
alors on va voir une autre séquence de
film là que valentin va nous montrer et
qui est une référence directe à ce blog
alors c'est plus c'est davantage la la
référence qui revient régulièrement par
audrey dussutour vous avez fait de
notamment une présentation tadic ce qui
est visible sur le web et sur youtube
intégralement dans cette cette
présentation vous mettez aussi
le passage du film alors qu'elle est un
film qui est un film d'horreur je sais
pas si c'est un film d'horreur vu
l'époque c'est les années d'abord c'est
les années 50 ensuite ya eu leurs
remèdes et dans les années 80 a encore
assez faut avoir parfois le l'estomac
bien accroché mais 50 maintenant il est
assez désuet et il donne une
représentation du blob lacrouts qu'on va
voir
bon ça ressemble à de la daj les
anglaises quoi il est rouge translucide
et c'est une grosse joly qui mangent les
gens et qui grossit et en réalité ce qui
m'a fait pas pour ça que j'ai surnommé
physarum le bloc parce que dans le film
le blog est grossier si vite que mon
fils aaron paul effa l'eau et à ce côté
vorace et du coup on le surnommait nos
laboratoires le blog tout le temps et
quand on a publié le livre en fête mon
éditrice avis il faut lui donner un nom
parce que qu'ils rendent toutes ces
femmes c'est trop compliqué je dis allez
toujours la belle le blog à la sig rouge
c'est une idée une idée de génie parce
que ça ça donne une vie terrible à cet
organisme alors on a des questions là
sur coelacanthe c'est la candide j'ai eu
mon blog s'appelle patrick c'est là
quand il aurait fait comme valentine
delattre il aurait levé son propre club
enveloppe s'appelle patrick i l'afem
deux fois mais là c'est bon on va voir
si elle sait le blop peut mourir à vous
disiez audrey dussutour que un blog ça
peut faire jusqu'à 10 mètres carrés 10
mètres carrés l'équivalent d'un bouquin
vous dites en garde inteligent tombera
et tout ça avec donc on l'a dit un seul
seul organisme une seule cellule en
cellule c'est une ces lâches cellule la
plus grande au monde en fait on peut pas
faire plus grande que les cellules
d'appui dont les voit pas à l'oeil nu
parce que ça fait quelques semble une
centaine de microns et voilà le bloc lui
les très gros et dans le laboratoire on
garde des blocs de belles centimètres
carrés environ
c'est déjà bien grossi alors déjà ce qui
est extraordinaire c'est que il ya une
seule cellule donc la cellule elle doit
savoir tout faire
elle fait l'oeil elle fait le nez elle
fait l'oreille elle fait le coup - elle
fait l'estomac
c'est exactement ça le blog il est
capable de sentir dans l'environnement
il perçoit les substances chine
etc etc il est capable de percevoir la
lumière donc il voit plus ou moins il
est capable de détecter l'humidité aussi
ambiante il va changer selon lui ni
déterminante elle pas comme ça sèche on
peut donc en fait il a vraiment des
récepteurs comme nous on peut avoir
d'essence sur toute sa cellule et ça lui
permet en fait de se déplacer en
fonction de ce qu'ils aiment et ce
qu'ils aiment pas ils écoutent et audrey
dussutour d'après les commentaires là
d'après les interventions de deux de nos
spectateurs on assure twitch il ya une
grosse communauté d'éleveurs de blog
puisque valentin 217 dit mon blog
s'appelle billy the bomb a brûlé sa
salsa chaque commentaire chasse à l'oeuf
donc j'ai du mal à les lire tous et on
va parler donc de la façon dont on peut
le nourrir puisque ya par exemple super
trois héros qui dit à noisy sur et des
bactéries
il y en a un autre qui regardent blanche
et flo condamne alors c'est un peu les
deux c'est comment sont peut-être dans
la nature parce que le blob
je trouve ce témoin des champignons dans
la nature le blog et manger champignons
et des bactéries les bactéries sont
authentiques tout petit après préfère
les champignons et dans le laboratoire
alors il ya un chercheur dans les années
60 et a découvert que il mangeait les
flocons d'avoine aoc pas comment il a
découvert ça il a peut-être partager son
petit déj comme je vois les gens ici on
l'avait tous des blobs donc j'imagine
qu'ils ont tous tester les nourritures
un peu différente
ce que le blog il n'aime pas que les
flocons mêlés fait qu'on a voté ce qui
marche le mieux mais il a une autre
chose j'ai des enfants qui ont mis la
betterave et le blog de pierre rose
c'est pas mal et pas tous les flocons
d'avoine parce que dans le boue que vous
dites comme il faut des flocons bio
peut-être par réflexe c'est pas écolo je
n'ai pas cru à l'arrivée ça marche pas
du tout à fait que blood américaine
c'est le difficile du groupe c le
capricieux du groupe
en réalité d'autres ism bielsa les
flocons d'avoine bio mais mon amérique n
aime pas ça et quand on doit nourrir nos
blocs de la même façon quand on crée les
la recherche est de coutume on est au
coin quatre lots bagarre parce que donc
là on commence à rentrer dans le vif du
sujet il ya plusieurs types de blob et
vous en avez vous travaillé sur
plusieurs types de blog mais avant de
rentrer dans cette danse éléments qui
sont déjà un peu précis
et puisque la question a été posée là
pas par leur parlant de cowes dit à quoi
ça ressemble un blob
peut-être que valentin pourra nous
mettre une image plein écran de ce à
quoi ça ressemble de quoi ressemble cet
organisme unicellulaire qui est très
très grand c'est un c'est un organisme
qu'on définit difficilement et on
définir en en disant il n'est pas dans
ce groupe il n'est pas dans ce groupe i
les parents c'est trente couples c'est
ça il est ni animales ou végétales
armand thiriez saoud réponse qui lui ont
fait du ni ni parce qu'en réalité en
biologie on apprend toujours aux enfants
qui a le règne des champignons leur line
des plantes et leurs ennemis des animaux
et le blog n'a aucun intérêt y voilà et
il ya beaucoup d'autres règne en fait et
donc lui fait partie d'un règne qui
s'appelle les années boulot et ses amis
et les amis c'est les cdc
les organismes qu'aucune cellule et qui
n'ont pas de forme en fait il peut
prendre la forme qu'ils veulent et ils
font des petites excroissances qu'on
appelle des pseudos co2 donc des pseudos
pied comme des petits doigts pour
explorer leurs environnements donc là on
voit bien sur cette photo le bloc des
partis connecter ces flocons d'avoine
avec ses petits pieds et du coup les
amis bauer ces cellules qui peu plate
forme est donc l intérieur qui est ce
elles sont très anciennes où je crois
que vous dites dans les 500 millions
d'années le bloggie les palha de benoît
n est pas tombé de la dernière pluie
un milliard cent millions d'années les
premiers alors au niveau de sa
reproduction là on a déjà des questions
m ndlr poser la question est ce que le
blog à plusieurs types sexuelle
effectivement il ya un an a dit excédé
globe la sexualité du bluff c'est bien
plus compliqué que que chez nous en fait
il à 720 type sexuel espérons des sexes
et les types sexuelle donc c'est des
gènes qui codent pour le sexe est en
réalité mondiale à 720 au moins ce qu'on
connaît à nos jours et pour se
reproduire il doit fusionner avec un
blog d'un autre type sexuel
donc ça veut dire que c'est à dire que
c'est un autre type sexuel donc c'est
beaucoup plus facile pour un bloc de se
reproduire que pour
ces cinq pour monsieur lange vraiment
qu'il ait pas de bol pour tomber sur
blocs d'accord une chose sûre cette
centrale
est-ce que ça a un rapport avec le fait
que le blog ça se reproduit très vite je
crois que vous dites que sa croissance
elle est exponentielle alors ça c'est
pas ouais c'est sa croissance et parfois
production parce que nous on travaille
sur le blog j'appellerais ça sa phase
adolescente la face végétatif c'est à
dire ce bloc qui grossit grossit et là
ils doublent voire triplent de taille ça
ça dépend développe tous les jours plus
tard polycéphale au double détail tous
les jours et en réalité dans la nature
quand il a atteint une taille assez 35
arrêts il rentra reproduction mais nous
aux laboratoires l'empêchent de se
reproduire en le regardant dans le noir
et en le nourrissant pourtant louis gros
si grossier et ça vous a valu des
contenus ça en labo un je vous racontais
que les parties à un soir sans vous êtes
parti en week-end et quand vous êtes
rentré vous allez vers le plaquage est
blob
c'est ça j'ai d'ailleurs ça répond à une
des questions de ce tchat
en fait les blogs quand il commença à
grossir et à sortir des bois il fusionne
avec leur petit copain d'à côté s'ils
sont génétiquement identiques et du coup
ça forme un énorme bloc et on l'a trouvé
au plafond skuhravy en réalité vraiment
les blocs faut les nourrir tous les
jours sinon ils sortent chercher de la
nourriture par eux mêmes et la fois dans
le petit container dans lesquelles on
les nids et du coup voilà il fusionne
les coûts avec un congénère en effet et
il fusionne comme ça ça peut durer ça
peut durer très très longtemps cette
histoire parce que on lit très
facilement à propos du globe et vous
même vous en parlait dans le tedx ou
dans le livre que le blog c'est une
créature qui est réputé immortel alors
bon voilà voilà une belle image hors jeu
c'est pas ça c'est quoi ces des boîtes
de pétri qui ont été ses seins voilà
qu'il est sorti la voie la plus forte de
ces boîtes
ça s'est passé après deux jours si on
lui donne pas un génie ce pas ça en fait
les cannois il me chercher à manger quoi
voila voila il montera sur le mur il y
travaille alors il va pas les preslois
ce qui n'a pas trop marché sur les
substrats les substrats qui sont très
secs ou qui rêvent toujours un peu comme
un verre ça
melbourne est gardé à limoux et
d'ailleurs il vint à quelle vitesse
alors le blog ils se déplacent ça dépend
là ça c'est pareil ça dépend des types
de blocs kona mais entre quelques
millimètres par heure jusqu'à 4 cm alors
quand même pour les plus rapides
quatre centimètres alors donc c'est pas
visibles à l'oeil nu mais vous avez
resté presque oui vous avez fait des
vidéos ou du stop-motion je sais pas
comment dire en tout cas où mon gros et
détail la table voilà et ayants droit
notamment boulotter des champignons en
forêt étonnant d'ailleurs il est
champion de pavés les deux ils s'en
fichent plomb oui il est pas et pas très
regardant sur les champignons il aime à
peu près tous les champignons qu'on a
essayé jusqu'à présent alors question
importante de thorgal de care qui a
peut-être vu le film le blog il est est
ce que c'est un danger pour l'homme
alors non pas du tout le blog il est pas
l'air gêne il sécrète très peu de
toxines
c'est pas du tout en danger il va jamais
ou angers ou quoi que ce soit vraiment
lui c'est une manche de petits bactéries
les choses comme il est vraiment
vraiment c'est aucun danger je le dis
souvent parce qu'il ya plein de gens qui
demandent si les enfants peuvent en
avant un oui ou pour en avoir la maison
et être à ce problème
c'est plus le gérer sa croissance qui
devient difficile pour les parents mais
met en regard on peut vraiment aucun
problème
gv n'ai aucune aucune déclaration
d'allergiques après tous les blocs
d'accord que 2 cm par heure c'est plus
vite que nous quand on était en
confinement nous dit un des internautes
j'espère qu'on n'y reviendra pas bon
finalement on verra enfin certains sont
déjà on a dit donc ce cet intérêt qu'il
avait pour manger à l'alimentation
finalement c'est quand même le grand ben
adda dans cette bien c'est sa grande
cession ou l'omi de il faut manger on a
dit que dans la nature c'était des
champignons des bagues en labo des
flocons et flocons d'avoine
mais comment comment finalement sait-on
qu'il qu'il apprécie tel ou tel ou tel
ou tel mais si je puis dire ça c'est des
expériences en labo vous avez mené
auriez-vous mais les quêtes vous avez
fait de la cuisine pour le blob
oui on fait de la cuisine pour le blog
mais c'est très facile à faire à la
maison qu'on appelle les manifs de
cafétéria quand vous mettez votre blob à
2,3 cm de nourriture ça peut être à bout
de carton gris et le blanc qui va vous
dire tout de suite si m6 a pas parce que
s'ils elles il ya les deux suites de
sucre varembé dessus et s'il aime pas il
va aller à l'autre bout eva critique
muraille de mucus comme centre lui la
nourriture le club va en réalité quand
on voit ce comportement comprendre les
basiques et laurie les installations
pour le jaune d'oeuf
oui il aime le gras le blog et le graët
les protéines mélanger il adore ça et
pourquoi parce que c'est une seule
cellule est donc en fait il est fait que
de gras et de protéines quasiment et
elle a besoin pour grossir il ya un
internaute qui nous dit qu'est ce que ça
veut dire qu'il a un mais oui c'est là
la question c'est super trop un héros et
rio qui qui disent ah c'est vrai si la
défaite qu'une seule cellule parle avec
l'artiste à dire cette lampe sur sa
membrane et du coup c'est comme si vous
laissiez le soudan fait le blob il a des
deux récepteurs aux goûts elle est qu'en
tirant comme ça ils goûtent le solde
et c'est comme ça qu'ils détectent et
petit substance qui diffuse dans
l'environnement passe quand vous mettez
par l'empreinte si oui il ya des petites
substances chimiques et vont diffuser
environnement et le blog pour les sentir
à distance alors beaucoup de questions
sur la façon dont on peut les levée
puisque vous avez dit que audrey dessus
pur vous avez dit que les enfants au
peuple et il n'y a pas de problème car
d'ailleurs à ce propos en faire juste
une parenthèse parce que j'ai fait une
petite accroche sur l'iss la station
spatiale internationale mais faudrait
pas oublier cette affaire en cours de
route
on avait prévu cet entretien audrey
dussutour de longue date à le 18 mars et
puis alors les journalistes disent
l'actualité a du talent moi je dirais on
a eu un bol de fou parce que aujourd'hui
le 18 mars il ya une vraie actu sur le
blog et c'est une actu spatiale il était
le brisage tout le bloc par sur 1700
avec thomas pesquet donc en fait on
appelle un vol cette année pour sa
mission et il va prendre avec lui quatre
blocs quatre petits globes et en
parallèle il ya 2000 écoles qui vont
pouvoir aussi faire la même expérience
que thomas pesquet sur terre puisqu'on a
préparé deux mille kits qui seront
distribués aux premiers premier arrivé
premier servi
allez sur le site du cnes s'est ouvert
sous un soleil au lycée 2000 bref temps
à préparer à fait de mille fois 3 c'est
le moment on est presque timide on est
presque tous bilan directement du vin
français je peux aller vite voir vos
profs leur dire je veux faire cette
expérience saison juste assez clair à
s'inscrire sur le site et ils vont
pouvoir faire finalement exactement la
même expérience que thomas pesquet y
recevront en fait les blobs les petits
papiers exactement comme thomas pesquet
et ils vont on va pouvoir enfin de
comparer le blob sur terre et dans des
conditions dans les conditions de la
halle de liesse c'est à dire en
micropesanteur donc on imagine que le
blog va peut-être un petit peu flotté
plus que d'habitude en quoi mon nom
parce que non
il en a vraiment fait tout attention on
a passé des mois tout est fait pour
qu'ils sortent pas navigué toute petite
membrane respirante titre ou pour être
sûr que même un tout petit pseudopode
passa donc y'a aucun doute étudiera pas
la vie est celle qui va pas être tout
jaune ça serait visuellement ça serait
top ça serait sympa j'allais dire
maintenant il faut quoi sauter ça
évidemment le film line
ouais c'est ça re life vous avez dit
tout à l'heure
quelques uns de tes quelqu'un qui dit ça
se mange un blog vous dit dans le livre
qui a une qui a une certaine je crois
tribu en amazonie qui le mange debout
il ya une communauté en amérique du sud
dans la cordillère des andes mais manger
un blog qui s'appelle alors qu'il avait
failli aux sceptiques à c'est le cousin
de pizarro alors lui la peine de lui par
contre il a plein de noms connus parce
qu'un anglais après les dogues vont
mythe romy de chiens en espagnol kkb
luna je ne vais pas traduire ça c'est
facile et il a les déjections de trolls
dans les pays nordiques et nous en
france comme on est des poètes quand
même on l'appelle fleurs de temps c'est
le premier parti dans vos jardins en
france n appelait ça ressemble à une
grosse éponge jaune il est un peu
difficile à garder la maison il faut un
peu l'entraîné c'est pas aussi facile
que figaro et cephalon mais ça se fait
pour les plus patients vous pouvez
regarder un frigo chez lui aussi
d'accord et donc ça se cuisine quoi si
on a la bonne recette et le fus ligot
alors il faut vraiment aimer ça parce
que la moelle et physarum polycéphale
homme et j'ai des enfants qui ont déjà
essayé de les goûter quand celle des
conférences dans les écoles et la
culotte on m'a dit que c'était vraiment
dégoûtant d'accord sur l'expédition de
dans l'es16 parce que il faut dire
effectivement que les astronautes quand
il passe six mois dans les ss et baïse
occupe partant à faire des expériences
impôts voir comment l'absence de gravité
sahin solution sur créances vous avez
dit tout à l'heure que les blobs vous
vous avez travaillé spécifiquement avec
des blogs américains japonais
australiens
les bleus qui partent dans l'espace la
leçon de quelle nationalité
alors c'est des blocs de laboratoire qui
viennent de leicester donc c'est un blog
semi anglais semi allemands 5 mx il
s'appelle le luc 352 vida vraiment
d'astronautes pour le coup et en fait
c'est le bloc qui a été séquencé dont on
connaît les génomes qui s'en va parce
que pourquoi on envoie ce club parce que
c'est notre warriors notre guerrier
c'est celui qui double de l'équipe de
taille tous les jours il se réveille
tout le temps on n'a aucun problème avec
une celui qui déborde beaucoup c'est
celui avec qui je fais toutes mes vidéos
parce que c'est vraiment le global notre
plus fort notre costaud on voulait pas
envoyer nos petits faiblard là où oui
c'est le blog choisir il y a rien
lecteurs qui disait quelle différence
entre l'ain pesanteur et la
micropesanteur je suis sûr qu'on ait
appuyé sur 6 2 sur sa venue à pois pour
répondre à cette question il ya une
question intéressante qui renvoie à une
précédente comme c'est bon les
ramifications mathématiquement très
complexe mais à quel point là on
pourrait citer une expérience dont vous
parlez dans le bouquin quelle expérience
de ce grand spécialiste japonais de blob
qui alors imagine photo là que va nous
montrer
expliquez-nous aubrée du sitour il avait
fait part hier de voir selexens de toshi
aqinac à qui donc si mon collègue m'a
appelé c'est le maître des blogs au
japon c'est monsieur globe
et alors ce qu'il a il a eu comme idée
de reproduire des petites cartes du
japon miniature alors il a mis le blog
sur tokyo et l'équipe wayne vous voyez
c'est des flocons d'avoine qui sont sur
les positions des villes autour de tokyo
et à l'orias au début de son congrès
mois la hongrie on a la carte du jeu ce
sont exactement et le blog lui alors il
s'étend il est chaque fois qu'ils
trouvent en flocons d'avoine il connecte
avec une veine ou parce que le réseau le
blog à l'intérieur du blogueur réseau
veineux et se raisonner et très optimisé
en réalité ce café toshiaki naka gars
qui sait de comparer plusieurs
paramètres dont le coût du réseau alors
un réseau qui est coûteuse c'est à dire
qu'il coûtera connecter toutes les
villes sont connectés mais ça coûte très
cher sans valise et il y avait de la
robustesse et à dire si on coupe une
veine baisse que le blog il peut
connecter tous les flocons d'avoine dont
il a comparé un petit peu tout ça et ça
ils savent eric le blog est un poil plus
efficace que le réseau ferroviaire
japonais ce qui l'était moins coûteux
mais tout aussi robuste
donc finalement l'étude du blog permet
d'abord des informations sur l'étude des
structures en réseau et ses implications
qui sortent de l'étude purement
animalière puisque vous êtes éthologue
roues
audrey taillée mais c'est là où ça
retombe sur des considérations qui sont
dans votre livre qui sont que l'étude
fondamentale et l'étude d'un organisme
comme celui-la comme le blog ça peut
déboucher sur des applications liées à
l'informatique par exemple très très
étonnante
oui tout à fait à l'heure actuelle je
travaille aussi avec des boîtes qui sont
par exemple qui veulent faire ce qu'on
avait du green haïti c'est à dire il va
le trouver des réseaux petit mot est là
et on travaille et que le blob là dessus
en réalité le blog il peut être source
d'applications en médecine en main en
sciences de l'informatique en fait il ya
eu pas mal de choses et a encore des
choses à explorer parce qu'il ya une
chose dont on n'a pas parlé mais j'ai vu
un peu passées dans le chat c'est que
cette immortalité du globe
si on trouve sans secret des gens sur
les prix contente finalement d'utiliser
secret du doigt parce que l'ocs pour
régénérer ce que nous ne pouvons pas
faire alors autre application qui serait
merveilleuse évidemment on n'y est pas
encore mais il ya un internaute qui
parle de cas parler de 2,2 de tumeurs on
sait que les tumeurs les tumeurs
cancéreuses pour croître
elles ont besoin de ramifications en
circuit veineux pour les alimenter or la
façon dont le blob est lui aussi servi
par son réseau de veines
ça vous permet de faire des comparaisons
et peut-être un jour
les spécialistes de la médecine du
cancer pourrait développer des systèmes
qui neutraliseraient les tumeurs c'est
ça alors ça c'est pas mon travail c'est
le travail de hans grunder dogora et nos
collègues allemands qui en effet est un
physicien années et il travaille sur la
vascularisation et surtout la mise en
place de cette vascularisation exergue
le blog continue to b b il a pas de gêne
les verts arrivent quand il commence à
faire en à 2000 mètres carrés et regarde
la formation de ses veines parce que la
formation de ses veines obéit aux mêmes
lois physiques que la formation des
veines au début
aussi ce départ les tumeurs raison pas
de veine non plus c'est un petit amas
cellulaire et puis quand la tumeur
grandi clairement elle court circuite
notre ve
parce que la réalisation est écrit sa
propre vascularisation pour nourrir
toutes les cellules cancéreuses
donc me regarde comment le bloc fonds
pour pouvoir et à l'affairé sur les
tumeurs à la haye beaucoup de questions
sur la couleur de nos blogs là qu'on
voit il ya quelqu'un qui dit médias 57
c'est une colorisation un internaute
précédemment pourquoi il est jeune non
non c'est des vraies couleurs n'y a pas
de colorisation d'albums
alors le jeune et il est jeune il a des
pigments qui qui en fait le jeune donc
c'est pour ça que d'ailleurs au départ
on avait pensé que toute plainte mais je
vais vous montrer en exclusivité
aujourd'hui un blob à pied rouge
alors je sais pas si on le voit très
bien mais les rouges voit pas très bien
la scène finale à la russe alla les
moins ragoûtants celui-là alors ça c'est
fise à rendre aux ehome c'est notre
nouveau blogue ses cousines physarum
polycéphale sommes allés beaucoup plus
loin et beaucoup moins intéressant et
patrice ans il sent une odeur assez
particulière le blog sans beaucoup la
forêt le jeune tué il sent la forêt mais
le rouet fixant llyod d'accord il est
japonais ce petit rouge et alors il a
été levée au bord de la mer ah ben je
sais pas mais en tout cas il s'en est
sûre le frais c'est très très rigolo et
alors il a une particularité aussi pour
les éleveurs de blocs qui suis là je
vois ils mangent la gare et mange son
substrat normalement le guitariste louis
se déplacent dessus et ils mangent les
flocons lui le rouchi creuse ils mangent
la gare ça c'est embêtant non pour le
dos si ça va être compliqué de les lever
on savait compliqué de les lever ça fait
que deux trois semaines koala et voilà
on va expérimenter dessus quand il aura
suffisamment grande
alors les salons du sentir chez désolé
non mais vous ne l'avez bien vous avez
donné envie on a envie de l'accrocher
dans sa voiture pour avoir des bonnes
odeurs dieu
il y avait une question sur le blog
pourquoi on l'appelle le blob alors il
faut je rappelle que cette émission vous
pourrez la retrouver intégralement en
replay sur le site web de sciences et
avenir alors elle sera visible encore
pendant quelques semaines sur notre
chaîne
twitch mais on va l'en capsules et dans
un article de science et avenir ça va
être sur notre chaîne youtube donc vous
pourrez revoir intégralement et entendre
les explications sur le nom du globe
évidemment il faut vous abonner à notre
chaîne switch sur s'en servir comme ça
vous serez avertis de toutes les vidéos
que nous faisons chaque semaine puisque
tous les jeudis à 17h30
on fait un direct comme ça une heure
trente de direct avec une scientifique
un scientifique pour parler de sujets
complètement différents puisque on a
fait la matière noire en cosmologie
on a fait les volcans avec jacques marie
bardintzeff la semaine dernière on avait
une de mes collègues sylvie roy tki
interrogé romain troublé de l'expédition
tara qui ai parlé des océans et de la
santé des océans donc ça va t'en tous
les sens il ya une question sur la
capacité d'apprentissage du globe des
internautes a dit comment il peut
apprendre finalement ce bloc question
vachement important dans vos travaux
comment il peut apprendre alors que il a
peu cerveau la question qui nous avait
fait à rodez il a fallu d'abord montré
que le blog est capable d'apprendre
alors il faut dire que le bonhomme il
apprendre des choses qui sont
relativement simples à son niveau ce
qu'il apprend le blog c'est à ignorer
les choses qu'ils n'aiment pas pour la
nourriture etc et on peut lui apprendre
ce qu'est ce qui leur arrive ou alors
ils aiment pas fait une chose il aime
pas toutes les substances amères pendant
que par exemple la quinine telexes ait
des tests la caféine que ce qui est dans
le café il est est sympa la vanille il
est pas de sel et donc on a réussi à lui
apprendre à ignorer ces quatre
substances alors que d'habitude vraiment
il est touché il va de votre côté et là
dans l'expérience est pas le choix il
veut y avait quand même des traversées
si vous les mangez donc on a montré avec
les jours l'entraînement le bloc
finalement à la fin ils montrés plus
d'aversion envers ces substances et on
s'est demandé du coup comment il a
produit là pas de cerveau est ce qu'on
s'est aperçu à prendre une substance il
la mange donc c'est un peu comme si les
enfants à prendre leurs devoirs il
devait démanger
le lobby fait ça en fait pour apprendre
à finalement à contrecarrer une aversion
ce qui fait c'est qu'ils avalent la
substance et du coup elle est à
l'intérieur
et du coup il fait plus trop la
différence trop ce qu à l'intérieur qu'à
l'extérieur et du coup il est baigné
dans cette substance et ils s'habituent
comme ça et on a montré que si on a
injecté avec une sereine d'être
directement la substance dans le blog on
allait le même comportement
d'apprentissage et c'est comme ça aussi
qui peut transférer cet apprentissage à
notre globe puisque les blocs peuvent
fusionner sont génétiquement identiques
et donc en un bloc avait appris quelque
chose
à l'opposé fusionner avec un alif hop on
laisse la fusion se faire pour l'aider
on est séparés dans le s'aperçut que les
deux globes et l'information quels
transferts qui s'est donc le blog ça se
passe assez bien alors neovacs se pose
la question comment peut-il vivre dans
les océans s'il n'aime pas le seul ils
vivent pas dans les océans à évident les
sahwa une milice paramilitaire
il est pas drôle le blog bêta d'halo
alors il a très peu il ya une seule
espèce j'ai vu qu'il y avait la question
comme il ya des espèces de blob il y en
a 1000 connu dean il estimé il ya une
espèce qui est légèrement aquatique on
retrouve souvent dans les aquariums
envoyé beaucoup cette photo il s'appelle
digne homme qui bloque blanc qui
viderait d'accord vous pouvez défendre
voire dans des terrariums aussi sortir
il ya deux questions là qui était
vachement intrigante
yanis et c'est les blobs ont-ils un adn
et une autre question que je vous l'a
dit avant de l'oublier qui disait le
blog a l'air d'être vachement bien
adapté à la 2d mais ce qu'on a fait des
expériences sur la 3d alors par rapport
à la dm alors par rapport à la dénouer
le globe a de la gueule comme tous les
êtres vivants en fait alors il a aussi
toujours pas comme yella chromosomes on
sait qu'elle n'a plus que nous il a un
génome qui est très long dans cette tour
par qu'il a commis là de chromosome ça
reste un grand mystère et pour la 3d
alors ça c'est une question vraiment
dans le pil poil puisqu'on a engrangé en
rendez vous il n'y a eu une réunion avec
les fêtes et spécialiste de ça la
semaine prochaine avec un américain on
va essayer de faire mon de faire grimper
le blog sur des petites fibres et petit
fils nanométrique
et pour voir si on peut faire monter en
3d on va voir si le toit mais en la
bonne il a déjà fait de faire des
piliers quand il aime quand on le met
dans un substrat sur un substrat des
tests en sur la vanne il à présent il
fait les piller il passe par le
couvercle
il s'en va donc il est capable on notera
l'absence d'école qui veut qu elle dit
ninja demandé à la question est en train
de défiler
est-ce qu'on est ce qu'on peut fusionner
différents types de blocs vous en avez
parlé un petit peu précédemment mais on
peut fusionner l'américain et le chili
et le japonais non alors oui ça oui euh
euh c'est les seuls parce qu'en fait ils
ont une problème de reconnaissance et il
fusionne mais l'américain mais en
réalité dans une seule des blogs
génétiquement identiques peuvent
fusionner en réalité vous savez les
blogs on peut les prendre les couper en
morceaux ça fait des morceaux
complètement autonome des blocs
autonomes donc c'est très pratique dans
l'élevage qu'on peut les couper couper
couples et donc on peut les refuser
sonné aussi mais des blocs qui sont
génétiquement différents ne fusionnera
mais si vous jouez à la maison vous
allez voir que par contre puisque hall
il n'hésite pas se coller à ce monde
extérieur on a vraiment l'impression de
sous
canac un accord mais en réalité si on
regarde de près son biais de ses parents
mais ils sont dans cette alchimie diablo
cette question sur l'absence de
connaissance sur le nombre de
connaissances de chromosomes ça intrigue
thompson 7 qui dit avec les techniques
de séquençage maintenant on n'y est pas
arrivé
c'est simplement combien d'occasions par
là là là on peut pas juger explique
pourquoi en fait le génome du globe est
très compliqué parce que je vais rentrer
dans les détails du coup pour cette
question alors vous savez le laden s'est
fait de base à cdg est en fait pour
faire pour lire le génome confisquant la
bêtise en utilise comme ça les grands
segments de l'adn
sauf que l'enzyme elle s'accroche bien
quand les bases change souvent mais le
blog il a des longs c'est des longues
séquences comme ça répétées de la même
base cgg gigi qui veut rien dire et j'ai
dit des couleurs aux emails saute et du
coup il fait des petits bouts donc on a
en fait c'est comme si le l'ademe du
blog à l'heure actuelle c'est un grand
puzzle mille pièces où toutes les pièces
seraient noirs et on doit re faire le
puzzle pour ce long sur 1 qu'elle sait
en faire donc le blob et des cyclones c
est ce qu on dit mais ni assemblée ni à
noter on n'a pas encore mis tout à bout
à bout et une fois qu'on aura tout mis
bout à bout on pourra le lire et
comprendre quels gènes venir alors une
question donné bulot sas ça ressemble
beaucoup au mycélium de champignons
peuvent-ils rentrée en symbiose avec
d'autres organismes
alors il n'y a pas de symbiose connu de
physalies cephalon avec d'autres
organismes
ça ressemble beaucoup au mycélium les
réseaux le réseau veineux du globe est
un peu plus compliqué mais ça ressemble
en effet elle ses formes un peu
arborescentes ressemble alors comme en
avait on a déjà eu beaucoup de questions
sur la façon dont on peut élever un blob
ou va ouvrir cette conversation a été
faire rentrer dans notre salle virtuelle
si je puis dire donc valentine delattre
bonjour valentine
bonjour alors valentine vous êtes
journaliste vous êtes vidéaste cessez
vos quêtes aux manettes de cette chaîne
sciences de comptoir qui explore la
géologie d'une façon tout à fait
singulière mais vous ne vous intéressez
pas qu aux cailloux puisque le blob g de
vos attentions il ya quelques temps en
fait j'ai retrouvé dans nos mac dans la
crypte c'est à dire mon bureau j'ai
retrouvé le l'exemplaire de haecht
axians un coup on compte des ensembles
valentine en fait en aidant à chaque
science vous aviez fait ce beau papier
pour lequel vous aviez interrogé audrey
dussutour on a adopté un blob et va
littéralement les journalistes qui
écrivent ce qu'ils font vous aviez
ramener un blob à la rédaction
et là il y avait toute une recette pour
expliquer comment comment le nourrir
comment le faire prospérer et je me
souviens qu'alors vous aviez un bureau
là qu'était et les vies de maintenance
bureau il est terriblement vite
valentine deux parties et il ya toujours
une fenêtre est sur le banc
par delà ce peut être la petite coupelle
mais grave erreur valentine parce que la
coupe elles étaient près de la lumière
oui mais la lumière n'était pas
directement dessus donc normalement ça
allen
je ne sais pas parce qu'on a dit audrey
le blog audrey audrey le blog même pas
le mien voilà le plat il ya pas les uv
en particulier et la lumière blanche il
déteste ça il peut rester une heure ou
deux vous pouvez largement le temps de
parler d'expérience depuis deux ans fait
ni si souvent cybers blanchi est bon
les sorties sont là pour leur donner à
manger et après je les ranger dans un
j'avais une petite valise que jamais au
travail tous les matins et je l'a ramené
le sourire alors valentine qu'est ce que
tu lui donnait à manger c'était les
fameux flocons de maïs de alors de
céréales ouais c'était des flocons
d'avoine et puis j'ai essayé de trois
autres choses j'essaie la bière aussi il
a beau coupé mais je sais pas si c'est
normal
oui c'est les love you are éleveurs cd
champignon unicellulaire donc c'est des
petits champignons donc il ya une
vieille yoga d'accord le blob est un
hipster
et voilà oui sinon c'était des flocons
d'avoine et puis puis voilà je crois que
j'ai pas fait l'expérience avec le
champignon
alors que ça me faisait très envie donc
je pense qu'il va falloir que je
réveille le blob pour faire sa alors
dénommée ensemble et bien je le dis si
oui oui la gauche le web ou sur des
sites web alors voilà ça c'est la voilà
c'est un filtre à café à la base est en
vacances en deux temps avec un puriste
blob est donc là le blob est endormi il
a en face de sclérotes si j'ai bien
compris
alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire et
puisque tour un blog endormi ça veut
dire quoi qu'il a pas il n'a pas les
aliments qui lui sont nécessaires ne
alors le blog quand il ya le milieu
commencent à se dessécher et qu'il a
plus on mange et glissant le stress
devenir est-il fait ces dix ans il s'en
kyste hyper toute l'eau il perd beaucoup
de choses il s'endort et sa forme un
petit week-end qui est on peut garder
les années ça on peut le garder dans des
alliances de tireurs
certainement c'est ce qu'ils parlent
d'ailleurs dans le sfc des blobs endormi
et c'est thomas pasquet qui va les
réveiller et l'ensemble vous vous vos 2
pour emilie serain c'est exactement ce
que vont recevoir voilà les enfants donc
c'est orange alors ce qui est absolument
génial c'est que quand le blob vie dans
la boue en version grosses cellules
il vieillit comme tout organisme on voit
qu'ils commencent des fois un peu a
peiné à moins grossier on le fait dormir
comme ça et quand on le réveille bas il
est rageant c'est complètement magique
c'est pour ça qu'on dit que le mode blog
est biologiquement immortel il est pas
immortel dans le sens on peut on peut
facilement tuer un blogueur du froid du
show de la lumière etc
mais si on s'en occupe bien nous nos
blogs ils ont plus de 70 ans il se porte
superbe pour raconter il ya au moins
dans votre dans votre livre
audrey dussutour qui a été cité
plusieurs fois dans le chat un donc je
pense qu'ils sont nombreux les
internautes à l'avoir lu dans tout ce
que vous avez toujours voulu savoir sur
le bloc sans jamais oser le demander
yahia un récit comme ça par une
américaine au texas
70 qui ça s'est un peu les ça a été dans
les journaux coin elle découvre un
intrus dans son jardin qu'est-ce qui
serait que ça le washington se dit en
fait c'est l'histoire de mary à risque
dans la lah sans jardin trouve un frigo
donc c'est un cousin évidemment un tout
petit globe et au début est tranquille
et pas très beau et donc en fait la
france son premier réflexe de l'exploser
avec un râteau donc elle est largement l
exposé en petits morceaux et
l'emmenèrent revient ayez toujours là il
a doublé de taille et du coup après
décide de prendre des insecticides et
pesticides et la danse ont la rage
d'être pulvérisé là ils liront violée en
verlan des boutons les i assez bon là
c'est réglé
launay reviennent il ya la paye d'une
pizza est vraiment là commence à
paniquer et dans le dessin raconte
qu'elle a appelé les pompiers
aspergeaient comme geddo il y en a
partout dans le jardin et le lendemain
elle est revenue d un mètre carré auquel
a appelé parce qu'ils sont est
l'histoire se passe au texas et à
l'appel du secoue les flics qui se font
qu'ils font quoi qui tire sur le blog
c'est réel
ils tirent sur le blog trouver des
petits trous dans le bloc mais ça lui a
rien fait du tout il a continué à
grandir et un jour il a disparu
mais là à l'époque on savait pas ce
qu'il avait fait en réalité russe
les terres entre art production dans
tout les sports était parti avec le vent
il y avait complètement disparu et la
seule explication qui n'en trouvait à
l'époque c'est parce que c'était
excellent aliens qui avait visité son
jardin et donc en fait le thème du
l'article c'était un épisode des simpson
nous dit kasaï
ça devait être à les tester dans les
années 70 à l'époque où les gens voyez
beaucoup du fo aux états unis et puis
l'on connaissait pas bien le blob à
l'époque même aux états unis alors que
le bénin ils le connaissent bien mais à
l'époque on savait vraiment pas ce que
c'était et c'est vraiment le fait
qu'elle a continué à regarder tous les
jours étrange alors valentine de tombes
l'acte avait appelé tylane parce que
bloc dylan ce que les moins de vingt ans
ne peuvent pas comprendre mais cherchez
donc dylan il a il a vécu sa vie pendant
ta réussi à en faire ce que tu voulais
quoi finalement c'est à contrôler sa
croissance où il ya un moment tu t'es
senti dépassé
non ça allait à peu près à peu près je
les gardais en vie pendant 2 3 mois je
crois et après donc je l'a endormi parce
que je parte en déplacement et que
effectivement mais quand on part en
week-end faut les emmener avec soi quand
je partais en reportage aussi je
l'emmenais du coup je les balades un peu
partout en france
il a connu les côtes bretonnes la
normandie le sud enfin c'est assez
chouette et j'ai oublié ta question du
coût non mais c'est donc ta ta ta
maîtrise et à maîtriser la chose quoi
élever un blog c'est vraiment la porte
et tout le monde n'y a pas beaucoup de
matériel il ya un internaute qui disait
moi je le fais je le fais pousser sur
sur des seaux pleins on peut en fait on
n'est pas limité pour que le coffre
humide une éponge ça marche aussi
alors moi j'ai testé sur des petites
boîtes de pétri que j'avais à la maison
donc je faisais là gelos com comment
labo et voilà est en fait effectivement
j'avais plusieurs boîtes et je faisais
un roulement
du coup ça fait beaucoup de vaisselle
mais je préférais faire ça parce que je
les connais dès le début parce que
j'avais peur qu'ils meurent et j'ai bien
fait parce que il meurt très vite en
fait et donc au final je l'avais j'avais
une tour de
si cette boîte de pétri comme ça et
c'était marrant parce que le soir des
fois ils se rendaient visite c'était une
fête des voisins est et je retrouvais le
matin dans un état pas possible donc
c'est assez rigolo mais ça fait beaucoup
wing blowin in the wind et video killed
the radio star d'attentats référence en
fait mais on le savait un que les
spectateurs de de twisted connaissent
cette référence évidemment bon yaya la
question quand même la façon dont on se
procure ce blog parce que le toit
valentine battu chaput avait directement
accès à la production si je puis dire
puisque j'étais en contact avec audrey
dussutour pour faire pour faire le
papier mais un internaute enfin un
internaute quelqu'un qui nous regardent
qui a un coût pour le blob et qui en a
qui a envie d'en avoir un à la maison
qu'est-ce qui fait il va pas dans
l'animalerie du coin enfin ou comment on
fait moins chaud si ces poires
maintenant patcher développent
facilement faire dans la capelette
sérieux qui vendent des blobs je vais
pas aller dire tous parce que je les
connais pas tous par carmen géant d'hier
trois au moins il ya le choc kit blob le
labo du globe
je crois lavaud développe shop kit globe
il ya le sort dahlab aussi yvan le
bolloc'h sa c4 que je connais sur le
bout des doigts et 6 avril pression
ebayi pas d'accord alors il ya un
internaute qui est géré son nom est
parti c'est la disparue c'est dommage
parce que j'aimais bien ça question il
disait si on rentre persyn verrai ce
globe les pouilles voilà c'était très
bien c'est faux les italia bloc marley
donc l'internet on peut on peut s'en
procurer sur internet parce que vous
voudrez dussutour vous raconter dans le
cas que vous avez établi votre
collection de blob ou à la faveur de vos
déplacements professionnels c'est bien
quand vous avez possédant un chapeau
quand vous avez fait des conférences au
japon et ses bras et pour ramener les
blobs à la maison en france à toulouse
enfin il fallait aller planquer quoi
ouais elle est cachée dans des bouquins
moi j'ai une amie qui m'a envoyé à
accrocher une carte postale en réalité
bon mais alors que c'est pas vraiment
c'est pas elle m'a dit qu'il existe un
36 des hommes politiques comme c'est
juste qu'il est hyper difficile à
trouver
pisan pourtant on en trouve plein de
l'autre mais lui
difficile et a maintenant c'est un peu
plus facile on se prêtent plus
facilement ce réservoir mais on se cache
et surtout c'est quand je suis rentré
d'australie
il a fallu que j'ai vu que quelques
demander comment bien un chercheur sur
les blobs en réalité un homonyme
spécialité de comportement animal et
après on peut travailler sur le blog
quand on fait les comportements de cry
sur n'importe quel organisme en réalité
et moi je ne cesserai de base sur les
fourmis
le blob est venue après c'est c'est une
c'est une découverte par accident alors
spécialiste des fourmis 1 c'est tenir
mais colog mien mais cologne c'est pas
mon corps maintenant pour les vélos tous
les jours non non mais alors c'est
vraiment les hasards de la recherche
quoi vous étiez en australie je crois et
puis une semaine avant de partir votre
chef de la bo qui vous dit j'ai un super
plan c'est ça en fait moi je travaille
sur la nutrition
je vais pour me émond au chef de la boue
il travaille sur une pression de chez
plein d'organismes il lui manque et
d'organismes unicellulaires et en fait
c'est très difficile travail faisant les
missiles bien parce que par définition
les voit pas c'est trop petit il voulait
absolument faire cette pièce de père
fouettard et c'est en discutant g savez
moi je connaissais les expose de toshi à
cognac accueille japon sur le blog et du
coup on a dit phil regard portera sur le
blog et ariana dans la vo d'à côté au
super en trois semaines nous avons fait
une manif alors on sait même pas ce
qu'ils mangeaient au départ du courrier
donner de la nourriture des fourmis
qu'on avait dilué
ça a été un peu compliqué on y croit et
finalement comme l'ex france n'était pas
finie la fois que je rentre en france
j'avais mon post cnrs et du coup je suis
en règle mais blog et j'ai continué
expérience arriver à tous
mais voilà ça a été il a fait comprendre
et cachés dans les valises le globo
australie bleu bleu beau logo proposé
trois maris leurs modèles alors là si
l'asse la collection il ya twitch ghost
qui dit quand on devient chercheur de
blob internationalement on est bloc
trotter y avait une question sur
[Musique]
alors le kiki qu à oye à 31,82 le blob
est sur toutes les bouches
façon de parler dans mon école depuis
qu'on a commencé en élevé dans ma classe
chacun veut son blog de compagnie c'est
trop marrant il doit y avoir une
communauté terrible en fait audrey
dussutour est sur des réseaux sociaux à
vous êtes sur twitter vous avez une page
facebook oui vous avez des gens qui va
qui vous vous posez des questions qui
vous demandent des conseils et
d'ailleurs je m'excuse mais
officiellement si je met du temps à
répondre fait c'est très compliqué mais
oui je suis quand même je vais j'y vais
au moins une fois par semaine je regarde
fasse un petit peu difficile de suivre
mais oui il ya une page mais il ya aussi
une autre page qui s'est ouverte par des
jeunes je crois travaille aussi sur les
blogs ou les gens partagent des
expériences d'élevage de blob
c'est très rigolo d'aller sur cette page
chez les gens qui se donnent des petits
conseils d'élevage
enfin le blog de finalement il a fait sa
vie autonome sur le web
peut-être comme des internautes va
trouver les références de cette de sept
pages de témoignages de lobby pour ans
et pourra nous de la cub lier la
question de air one était intéressant
alors j'ai perdu là la question de r moi
peut-être qui pourra nous l'a reposé
depuis quand ça existe avant les
dinosaures
alors ne pourra en avant les dinosaures
10 avant les dinosaures parce que les
premiers spécimens de mick smith est
donc ça c'est la classe d'orgue à tous
les blogs on pense que c'était il ya un
milliard d'années à peu près donc
c'était pas physarum police est pas le
bac tu es là mais c'est quelque chose de
personnel
il y avait il y avait une question alors
les éleveurs comme comme toi valentino
ou puis sans s'en rendre compte on a
compris que qu'est-ce qui est telle
entre ans c'est à dire qu'est ce que
manger le blog des flocons d'avoine
mais qu'est ce qu'il en sort du blob est
ce qu'il ya des défécations de blob
bah oui oui comme tout en galice milan
sa remplaçante est donc oui et
d'ailleurs c'est comme ça qu'ils se
repère entre eux c'est drôle comme
l'hôte manger au large de plein de
choses dont le calcium en grandes
quantités et les autres blob ça veut
détecté en fait ce calcium à distance et
c'est comme ça qu'ils se retrouvent dans
une boîte de pétri
ils sont attirés les hommes par leurs
déjections qui est mignon ça c'est des
petites donne sa valentine tu as vu ça
il fallait nettoyer la ville couleur
jaune oui c'est une couleur particulière
oui ou une espèce de bave aussi j'ai
remarqué quand il quand il sortait de sa
boîte il pouvait se faire un espèce de
petit filet on bave étrange un peu trop
ça c'est le mucus
alors là c'est autre chose voilà le
mucus selon elle sécrète en permanence
le blob en fait il a besoin de s'isoler
de la sécheresse est donc en fait ils
sécrètent comme un manteau pour se
protéger de la dessiccation il sécrète
du monde puisse tout le temps et il
utilise aussi son mucus des fois pour
s'isoler intéressante sera quelque chose
qu'il apparaît que les murs avec son
opus et ce mucus il utilise comme une
mémoire spatiale
parce qu'il utilise sont plus pour
savoir où il a déjà exploré parce que ça
lui sert comme dira bel âge de la vie
faussement vécu ce match est déjà été là
je pose mon mucus comme ça il peut
explorer parvenir ou tourner en rond
c'est donc une forme de navigation
destinés petit con avait publié en 2012
je crois et qui était donc sur la
mémoire spatiale développe donc c'était
vraiment comme les fourmis laisse des
petites races
il ya un internaute qui a retrouvé
l'adresse de la page dont vous parliez
audrey dussutour ces témoignages
d'éleveurs de blob
ça s'appelle blob france c'est jojo
tirer mgt qui a retrouvé la la référence
film stone pose la question quelle est
la place de ce petit organisme dans
l'environnement sa nouvelle adresse code
civil
comme tous les organismes et une place
belgique plus d'organiser les eaux ils
sont connectés à d'autres et lui il est
connecté surtout avec les plantes c'est
à dire que le blob image aux bactéries
champignons dans la nature et les
produits de la digestion tout ce qu'il
veut pas il regarde dans l'environnement
et cd micro éléments pour être
interpellé par les plantes que les clans
que ça mange pas des gros flocons
d'avoine ça mange des éléments des
petits atomes décision et pour ça il
faut que ce soit prédit gérés par des
organismes et le globe il est là prédit
gérer ces choses qui relate dans
l'environnement et des plantes peuvent
gérer et les champignons aussi donc il
est d'un petit peu près dix gèrent c'est
un peu comme les un peu comme les
descriptifs or ce n'est pas le
détritivores mais ceci alors justement
ça ça fait un bon lien avec la question
de coco yahia qui dit que lui il le fait
travailler son blob ils l'utilisent pour
assainir sa poubelle
oui j'ai déjà qu'il met dans le compost
aussi alors c'est pas aussi bon que les
verts il parlait parce que j'ai des amis
qui ont mis des blocs partout doivent
composer ce blog soit ils sortent ils
explorent le couvercle et servira botton
et la semoy en place que les verts mais
oui on peut mettre souvent parler des
enfants trop de blocs jeudi aux parents
mais si vous avez dû composent mais
qu'elle est dedans ça va l'occuper o
globo a aussi rejeté dans la nature
alors son remplaçant nous dit quand
j'entends le mot blog ça me rappelle un
film d'horreur des années 90 alors j'en
profite pour dire que on a évidemment
fait une référence à à tous et filmant
en début d'émission on est ensemble avec
leurs audrey dussutour et avec valentine
delattre depuis 17h30 et l'intégralité
de cette émission sera visible en replay
sur la chaîne twitch de sciences et
avenir
mais ça ça dure que quelques semaines
elle ne sera pas
de façon définitive jusqu'à la fin des
temps jusqu'à ce que les blogs meurent
de vieillesse sur le site web de
sciences et avenir sur notre page
youtube vous pourrez revoir tout cet
entretien et notamment les références à
ses films de blob capitaine you knew
pose la question on voudrait pensez vous
que ces recherches peuvent apporter dans
le domaine médical alors on en a parlé
tout à l'heure où on a dit que les
spécialistes du cancer s'y intéressent
et mais là où captain ils nous posent
régénération de membres c'est vrai
qu'après par la régie on en est loin un
petit peu c'est plutôt la régénération
cellulaire qui nous altération petit peu
comment la cellule en fait se débarrasse
alors le vieillissement cyber comment ça
marche la cellule elle s'oxyde est là qu
ils sont près du stress oxydatif
on aimerait bien voir comment le blog il
se débarrasse de ce stress oxydatif
parce qu'ils en il a oscillé aussi il a
aussi ce stress oxydatif
quand il dit donc ça existe chez lui
aussi mais il est capable de sonder bras
fait ça ce serait super si vous pouvez
voir quelle est sa formule magique pour
se débarrasser de ce stress oxydant et
c'est quelque chose qu'on attaque en ce
moment là comme recherche c'est très
récent
j'ai une étudiante elle parce que la
taille de sud est lgv et 9 passes c'est
vraiment ça on peut-être rendre agréable
parce qu il a aussi des caractéristiques
en termes de cicatrisation qui sont je
sais pas un véhicule dans le règne
animal on voit sachets ou alors ils
disent ici catherine à moins de deux
minutes et son cytoplasme donc c'est le
liquide qui à l'intérieur de la cellule
qui est un petit tout comme le centre du
globe coagule très rapidement donc on
connaît pas exactement qu'on se fait ce
phénomène non plus et en médecine pour
la dernière application possible c'est
que le blog comines enjeux des bactéries
et des champignons il sécrète surmontant
des antifongiques et les antibiotiques
mais on les connaît pas encore peut-être
qu'ils en ont les peut-être que c'est
des individus commun qu'on connaît déjà
parce que ça met des nouveaux il
faudrait que des chimistes se penche un
peu le dessus
c'est vrai que nous en tant que
idéologues spéciale du comportement
c'est un peu le web pour nom ce type de
recherche mines
il faut être il faut d'autres chercheurs
que des nouveaux chercheurs sur le blog
on est par ces mots
y a pas déjà une collectivité ça doit ça
doit partir dans tous les sens les
horizons scientifiques en double oui
alors en france on est peut être honnête
on n'est qu'à trente cinq 35 ans au
japon il ya là beaucoup c'est pour la
petite histoire c'est parce que l'on
peut ravir au heat au adoré les knicks
au 17 et les collectionner et il a même
écrit un livre sous un faux nom où il
parlait des blogs et du coup nous avons
souvent fait ça ça fait que la recherche
sur les blogs au japon elle est vraiment
encouragé ses finances
et pas forcément le cas partout ea et du
coup les ya beaucoup de chercheurs ont
vraiment la plus grande partie à la
recherche de la fête au japon sur les
blu ray vous dit dans le livre vous
racontez comment vous avez visité la bo
du grand spécialiste japonais peut-être
à tout peut-être à tokyo je sais pas
mais c'était vraiment ils ont du
matériel quoi ça montre aussi bien oui
là où certains voient le le décalage qui
peut dire moi j'étais sale a booké super
magie a été deux fois on est retourné
après avec jacques mitsch de réalisateur
du film pour voir dauchy et seront un
labo exceptionnel d'hô chi tam être
incroyable vraiment super sympa aussi
vraiment c'est le paradis pour des gens
alors jacques mitsch c'est le
réalisateur du documentaire qui
s'appelle le blog un génie sincèrement
que park avait été diffusé sur arte 1
avec votre tour on le trouve encore sur
une autre page officielle de dart est un
jeu jean députés j'en ai vu des extraits
sa chair défi des morceaux à lille et en
intégralité team devait cadets demande
quand est-ce qu'il sortira il est déjà
il est déjà accessible et déjà visibles
il y avait une question sur sur les
prédateurs est ce que est ce que le blog
a des ennemis à une question
précédemment disait ce cas certains
virus qui peuvent qui peuvent avoir sa
peau
alors les virus attaque tous les
organismes vivants dont même le bloc
peut avoir des virus or nous n'en a pas
eu pour l'instant où la boue mais il
pourrait attraper et son prédateur le
plus redoutable c'est la grimace
bien qu'elle soit très loin séquelles
plus rapide que le blog mais il peut se
défendre un peu il nous paraît une
petite anecdote pendant le tournage avec
jacques mitsch en avait un terrarium de
deux mètres sur deux on avait recréé la
nature et on avait donc ramener les
choses et d'autres et l'image françois
et pendant le film pendant confirmé le
bob gainey vaste et demi comme ça bon
goûter notre blog et de solaire totalisé
complet elle s'est arrêtée
hélas le blog lui a foncé dessus moi ça
manger son mucus qu'il est parti et la
limace cuit par s'est réveillée donc on
s'est dit que le bloc devait sécréter
une petite toxines pour anesthésier les
limaces et on l'a vérifié ça avec une
collègue et aux laboratoires dali avec
des petits la mère des petits verres
plats on a jeté sur le baudet pareil à
londres pénalisé comme ça le blog n'est
pas sans défense
il doit être traité un petit
anesthésiant caisse comme ça valentine
quand tu quand tu avais ton petit
élevage de blob là on a passé des
morceaux à des camarades je crois même à
l'intérieur même de la rédaction sur tf1
occupée tu te rends tu t'es rendu compte
que tu pas comment dire à tout comment
tu le couple commence à se manipule et
avec et est allé dans sa boîte et on le
coupe en deux avec du coup donc aux et
8,2 de cicatrisation ça se constate il
se passe quelque chose quoi il reprend
ça fait deux formes différentes comme
comme 2e au plein alors qu'ils sont
amoureux et se disjoint way à peu près
en fait on peut pas le prendre tout seul
parce que c'est juste une cellule avec
une membrane cellulaire au tour donc si
on le prend on casse la membrane et ça
devient juste un espèce de pigeonneaux
coeur on peut pas tellement de
transporter et quand on veut le alors je
ne sais pas il est mort à son ombre oui
quand on va sur l'écrasent le blog gamer
il faut pas l'écran faire d'accord on
peut le coupé sa cicatrice direct mais
par contre comme disait lundi non peut
pas vraiment le premier est pas moi il
le prendra part avec ses flocons quoi où
et prendre avec ses flocons jours et que
son succès voilà donc en fait je
découpais un bout avec la
le gel dagar qui est en dessous et c'est
ce petit bout là que je mettais sur un
autre gel dagar dans les nantis c'est
quoi ces jeunes bagarre c'est moi je
connais la gare à gare où la grâce il
faut faire les bateaux mais c'est quoi
le gélat daga ça se casse la fête à
informer les internautes poser la
question disait ce qu'il faut avoir des
comics pour élever son blog a priori il
en faut pas mais là dont déjà tu rentres
densité qu'est ce que c'est
alors c'est pas obligé d'utiliser ça
mais c'est ce que audrey utilisé et du
coup j'ai fait pareil et donc en fait
c'est un gel qu'on fait avec de l'eau
dans une casserole qu on fait bouillir
et on met dedans de l'agar agar un petit
peu pour la solidifier enfin c'est donc
c'est du oui c'est de la gelée d'eau en
fait pour avoir un substrat humide sur
lequel le blog puisse rester sans se
dessécher et donc on en remet juste dans
le fond des boîtes et voilà il faut
changer régulièrement parce que sinon il
ya des des bactéries ou des choses comme
ça qui se développent de suez qui
viennent manger le bloc donc c'est un
peu délicat d'accord voilà et j'avais
une question qui l'instant je puis me
permettre
vas-y vas-y aux gens profitent que
qu'audrey soit là pour lui poser une
question
j'ai vu passer une question à propos des
sports dans le chat et j'ai fait une
petite expérience une fois je lui ai mis
du liquide de e-cigarettes dessus donc
je pensais la nicotine qui n'a pas du
tout aimé mais vraiment tellement pas
qui s'est mis à faire des sports en fait
je voulais savoir ce que ça voulait dire
je sais que la cafice d'être a aussi
suivi la spoliation par la sporulation
c'est aussi un ça va pas du tout le
globe il fait ça pour se reproduire mais
aussi c'est une forme de résistance
comme l'aspect rente et du coup il fait
des scores quand il n'est pas content
cela sport est elle pire pareil à 10 ans
15 ans 20 ans nous avons trouvé dans
l'ambré tout m'est donc c'est une forme
de résistance de qui là car on peut
aimer quelque chose et c'est pas si mal
que cela dit quand il a une vraiment pas
ibr aussi flambé du poison dessus il
nord où ils sacrifient il fait de mon
appel ça l'autonomie je crois à tout
auto ming chi kuo c'est comme les
lézards qui enlève l'or que le blog est
sacré in paris lui d'accord va se
développer mais c'était joli les sports
on aurait dit du caviar presque des
petits
montrer très belles sont en noir et en
sont les regarde à la loupe binoculaire
dit vraiment un truc pour nous trouver
dans les écoles là elles sont iridescent
elles sont noires mais elles ont toutes
un arc-en-ciel dessus c'est hyper des
ingénieurs alors rien à rien à auphelle
qui fait un commentaire et 17 olemps
turin contre ballantyne parce que il
paraît que le tabac c'est mauvais pour
faire du sport je lis ce qu elle alors
remercié remercie les sk y z under ce
corps y zz qu'a fait un don de vous
pouvez vous faire des bonds tijeras
confère des sables à un valentine tu
parles de twitch non on fait des seuils
ça fait des sa version pour le train de
la bâtir les archives tout à fait oublié
ses clés laitières mais je sais que
l'intéressé vraiment version alors y at
which ghost rider je me permet de
reposer ma question le blog possède-t-il
la capeb la capacité d'apoptose alors
l'apoptose c'est la mort de la cellule
mort cellulaire
donc c'est des cellules qui regarde
quand on dit qu'à rentrer en apothéose
elle se sacrifie en fait l humeur et
nous on n'a pas vu d'apoptose chez le
globe à chaque fois que le blog est mort
c'était notre faute s'est jamais
développe qui avait décidé de mourir
alors soin c'est ce que disait vendu ces
contaminations mais on n'a plus du tout
même si on a bien su maîtriser ça mais
en fait les contaminations la plupart du
temps c'est parce que des gens dont 3
manger au bloc parce que les
contaminations et viennent du flocons
d'avoine et quand on en trois manches et
notre blob le flocons d'avoine à 20
degrés dans un milieu humide belle sacré
de la contamination donc il vaut mieux
affamés un petit peu son blog pour
éviter ce genre de problème et après du
coup on peut comme ça garder votre sang
blood un peu plus longtemps
alors si on travaille dans les
conditions stériles non alors moi je
croyais pas du tout dans les conditions
stériles honnêtement try and consulting
sait c'est très très difficile en
laboratoire et surtout lobby n'aime pas
on a déjà ce qu'on appelle stériliser
ses flocons d'avoine dans les amis dans
une autoclave une cocotte-minute comme
et quand un gars donné les flocons il
les a beaucoup moins élevé
qu'habituellement parce que le blog il
aime bien le microbiote qui vit sur les
flots comme aussi parce qu'il aime bien
les micro-organismes donc quand on se
tait l'iss où il fait un peu la tête
alors c'est quoi la taille la taille
maximale d'un glaude c'est quelque chose
qu'on a payé en début d'émission
vous parliez de 10 mètres carrés mais en
fait c'est parce qu'on n'a pas réussi à
ses envies dans la vie plus on avait
pensé avec la venue de faire un blog
géant mais c'était trop de temps alors
on a bien essayé à l'apparition revoir
en replay que c'était ni un champignon
ni un animal ni un végétal mais on sait
que dans le règne des et des champions
mais qui peuvent avoir la taille d'une
ville quoi ça peut aller très très loin
oui oui
d'ailleurs je vois dans les commentaires
qui est quelqu'un qui dit dans le blog
le land le plus grand c'est 10 km alors
c'était un petit peu particulier c'est
moi qui rapporte cette anecdote dans le
livre où on a retrouvé en effet le même
blog soit 10 km car il n'était pas
entièrement connectée c'est juste qu'ils
devront trouver des bouts de blob sur
dix qui m'accueille c'était toujours le
même
donc en effet il était complètement
contaminé une aire de 10 km mais il
n'était pas entièrement connectée tous
les couples parce que quand on marche un
blouson le séparant des aînés c'est sa
voix au le 10 pers façon puzzle
twitch ghost dit je nous crois pas qu
audrey et répondu sur comment déterminer
l'âge d'un blog c'est vrai vous avez dit
vous avez en a beau des blocs 70 à leur
roi au laert est parti c'est pour ça que
j'ai dit au moins soixante dix ans parce
qu'on ne connaît pas l'âge de nos blogs
nous on les a récupérés dans un
laboratoire avec carolina qui les a
depuis 70 ans
ils les ont récupérés dans la nature on
ne sait pas l'âge qu'avait ce blog alors
nous quand on parle d'âge du blog ses
eaux du moment où le réveil de la
dormance on le laisse hélas on va dire
assez un bloc de ciment as un bloc de 7
mois mais en réalité il est bien plus
vieux que ça puisque avant la dorna blog
qu'avant donc en réalité l'organisme le
génome l'unité génétique et bien pu dire
que ça mais nous quand on parle d'âge de
nos blogs c'est au moment où on les
réveille comme la petite carotte à mon
très vite tout à l'heure à partir du
moment où elle est réveillée mondiale
blob dix jours est en réalité voilà une
au blog ce qu'on a parce qu'on en a de
plusieurs commandes ise origine c'est
toujours des feeder un policer fallon
d'australie du japon les états unis
on connaît pas leur âge actuel mais son
vieux au moins ils ont tous au moins le
plus de 50 alors deux questions qui se
rejoignent alpha mos o'shea brawl blob
at-il fille at il évolué mutek et depuis
sa création il coque pose la question le
blob était pareil à un milliard d'années
ou est-ce qu'il a évolué et encore il a
évolué voilà un trio parce qu'on en a il
a évolué mans il évolue très lentement
mais comme tous les organismes il évolue
vraiment très très lentement parce qu'il
y avait un faux
il ya 40 me en ami il avait regardé et
finalement il n'y a pas beaucoup de
différence avec le globe actuelle mais
il évolue quand même et on peut avoir
des mutas des mutants on a des mutants
mais c'est des mutins de laboratoires
qui ont été faits en ce qu'on appelait à
l'époque la mutagenèse dirigée c'est à
dire que vous ira dire au bloc
regardez donc nous on a trois blocs
béton au labo non un albinos donc
suffisamment pression cépages qui est
dixit pour leur aide alors la loi 12
duke of york bz street 77 il vient
d'arriver sur le direct il pose d'action
c'est quoi un blog un champignon non
ceni un champignon n'y avait jettent
aliens animal vous pourrez revoir un
tout là toute la vidéo en replay sur le
site de sciences et avenir dès le début
de l'émission
on parle de ces questions là est il
capable de 6,6 parité
oui sur certaines bizarrement quand on
lui donne une nourriture très enrichi en
protéines galets fait des flancs
hyperprotéiné avec des protéines coin
qu'ils pour les salles de sport hélas le
bloc ne fait des pelles ptitblog
alors que d'habitude il fait pas ça
c'est nous qui le faisons nous emporte
pièce mais lui il ne fait pas
naturellement
l'aviron se séparer en dur morceau mais
il le fait quand le sucre est très
riches en nourriture et donc on pense
que c'est parce que du coup il a cette
capacité à se dire bon ben là je suis
dans un très enrichissant de me séparer
du procureur fait partie dans plusieurs
directions
mais on avait un commentaire très sympa
de 2010 qui disait je viens juste devant
je suis arrivé de plus pas très
longtemps mais je voulais vous dire que
c'est super que voilà je suis arrivé il
ya peu sur le live mais je tenais à vous
dire que super et la façon dont vous en
parler est vraiment captivante est tout
simplement génial merci une excellente
continuation
l'offre science basse et sage comme ça
faire pleuvoir sur le fil twitter et
facebook etc
les preneurs les preneurs
le le les découvertes sur la santé on en
a pas ce gosse x on a parlé plus tôt
dans l'émission tu tu pourras le
réécouter il ya vraiment c'est ce qu'on
voit la science fondamentale comme ça
qui se penche sur un sujet qui peut
paraître comme ça étrange voire rigolo
et ben ça peut déboucher sur des sur des
découvertes fascinantes et surtout
qu'ils ont un impact sur la vie de tous
les jours et dans la question eric la
question du globe on est aussi dans ces
considérations là le blog est-il
comestibles ça aussi audrey vous vous
avez parlé de ça vous avez dit qu'ils
avaient une tribu en asie et en amazonie
ouais mais vaut mieux pas les manger on
est membre
pizarro positif à l'homme il est rédigé
il va pas vous empoisonner les indigeste
hockey des gens qui soutiennent qu'on
prépare à faire de la farine comme les
farines animales pour ça je déconseille
en plus à moi je beaucoup trop de
flocons d'avoine autant prendre les
flocons directement oui mais c'est vegan
parce qu'il souffre pas c'est le bloc
souffre alors on croise souvent la
question à ce que le bloc ce système
nerveux mais alors il se trouve il n'a
pas la souffrance qu'on l'appelle donc
je prends ce qu'on veut mais il peut
être et c'est donc on peut voir quand le
blog déstresser quand il aime pas les
clauses qui est pas content il tremble
mais ils ont mis fait des structures il
ya moi je trouve ça hyper le prouver eh
bien il ya voudrait ça me fait penser à
une à quelque chose c'est tiré avec les
araignées il y avait eu des expériences
sur l' usage des drogues et on avait vu
que les araignées selon les drogues
qu'elle avait ingéré elle pouvait faire
des étoiles avec des formes complètement
tarabiscoté non enfin si c'était du lsd
c'était telle forme et si c'était je
sais pas moi
une prog secret entre eux ben c'était
une autre forme peau est ce qu'on a fait
des expériences et un peu dans ce goût
là avec les blogs ça aurait un saut ce
qui prendrait des forme d'hexagone je
sais pas moi alors moi j'ai donné de la
cocaïne et après des neurosciences dans
mon laboratoire
il y as détesté
ont été signalés sur le plafond de la
boîte
il a même pas vous y allez c'est la cata
c'était vraiment l'horreur par contre on
a fait des tests plein substance que ce
qu'on voulait voir à quel point il était
capable de déceler dans l'environnement
des substances dont les perturbateurs
endocriniens et on avait testé tous les
antidépresseurs les hormones et et de
blob dorothy dépresseurs et ils ne
détectent mg par litre 10 mg par litre
c'est vraiment mais c'est rien c'est
trois graines dans un grand lit trop tôt
et si on lui donne à explorer un
substrat il n'y a pas là un petit
dépresseurs et un substrat lundi
dépresseurs ils préfèrent aller du côté
il ya là un petit buzz incroyable à ses
trousses précédent bordeaux d'accord
d'accord à bukavu encore une fan du blog
je vous jure qu'on parle du blog sur
twitter je trouve la raison de alma au
très intéressant de tracts et j'ai raté
la question d'or où se reproduit suite à
suite à des stress il a donc une
certaine sensibilité est bon c'est un
petit peu ce que la voie la question de
sensibilité la souffrance oui le bloc
conseils de son frère aîné c'est une
très bonne question est très bonne
question si vous venez juste d'entraîner
votre blob par exemple à aimer le sel ou
à aimer la caféine ci voulant dormait
juste après pour le faire juste après et
que vous le réveiller un an après 1 mois
restants avaient en effet don qui garde
sa mémoire à long terme et on a montré
qu'en réalité c'est parce qu'il garde la
substance à l'intérieur de la cellule
dont qui gardent bien de cette mémoire
de la substance
expérience avec l'électricité ou là où
la pression d'un fluide qui seraient
exercées sur lui c'est une question de
ckoi jol jeune bûcheron comment le blob
réagi face à l'électricité alors il ya
un mois je n'ai pas fait mais j'ai un
collègue qui a montré qu'ils étaient
très conducteur donc qu'ils s'amusaient
mais le blob est pas trop gêné par les
courants électriques en mode pause et
beaucoup la question sont les coins les
l'électromagnétisme mais j'avoue qu'on
l'a jamais fait nous n'avait testé par
contre pour le faire avant qu'il parte
en liesse
on avait testé plutôt la forme de
d'hormones sclérose pour voulait voir
qu'est-ce qui pouvait résister aux
vibrations au froid ou chaud on a vu
qu'on pouvait le mettre jusqu'à 80
degrés en bord ans on peut le mettre à
-80 on peut mettre au micro de cinq
minutes quand il est en dormance selimi
survie le quintile en dormance il est
vraiment en mode de résistance par
exemple pour la police il faut les
stériliser on peut pas envoyer un blog
tout prades avec ces bactéries et a donc
on le met on le plonge mais pas de clans
dans le plan gens là dans l'alcool
absolut donc salle colas 99 points en
mai dans l'alcool absolue ont leur sort
très vite fait en le meilleur la javel
on en sort très vite et on le remet dans
l'alcool ressent et là on laisse sécher
très rapidement et il revit après il est
stérile sur tout et il est propre
c'est génial on est à plus de rouler à
plus de 6000 spectateurs ont cessé vache
c'est super on est très content merci à
tous d'être là abonnez-vous à la chaîne
pour être au courant de direct que nous
faisons sur la chaîne de sciences et
avenir tout
et tous les jeudis à 7h30 il y avait il
ya deux jours mgt qui demandent combien
d'aces vous audrey comme une espèce de
blogs
vous avez alors qu des variétés de
physarum polycéphale on a là une
quinzaine mais d'espèce on a trois
actuellement il à rendre aux ehome et
bada lien strict live et jérôme
policiers alliance et c'est le nom de
l'espèce c'est le nom du service
pourtant il n'y a dit m un espace béant
dans la 3d space on n'a bizarrement pas
l'eau mais en quinze variétés qui
viennent de zones un peu différente
donc c'est des individus la dent voilà
c'est ça en afida rendre aux ehome voilà
hélas celui qui est pas très ragoûtante
qui fêtera halloween et on n'a pas
d'avenir que j'ai pas la veille
d'accord et alors milo 92 je suis arrivé
il ya 20 minutes je vais regarder le
replay sa wii très bien beau réflexe
pourriez-vous dire un mot sur l'intérêt
éventuel dans l'optimisation des réseaux
oui ça c'est aussi une question dont on
a parlé assez longuement ou alors que
vous pourrez le replay est ce qu il
survit en milieu anaérobique demande des
bulles hausse
non pas du tout le blog il a besoin
d'oxygène il respire si vous c'est pour
ça qu'à la maison qu'on voulait garder
dans des ghettos perwer il faut faire
une mini trous dans le pervers parce que
sinon le blog gagne pas ça il respire il
a besoin et un peu d'air qui rentrent
dans la boîte en faut pas qu'elle soit
grande ouverte pour garder l'humidité
mais des petits trous alors il ya une
question aussi eu lieu sur le nom mixo
mills est le mix omis cette c'est aussi
le nom scientifique du blog mais c'est
un nom qui porte un peu à confusion
parce que je crois que ça veut dire le
champignon gluant
oui alors la mx ont mis sept la classe
dans laquelle épisode vous avez les
années bohème grand règne et à
l'intérieur des classes il ya la classe
des mix ou i7 et là il ya dix mille
espèces et là vous avez trouvé bizarre
en plus donc les knicks ont mis sept
vous allez voir c'est une place mais il
y a
variété ya pas que les les blogs comme
on voit avec les réseaux il ya les
knicks christine accéder bull juste
l'ico galles avant de céder petite boule
rose on dirait les fraises tagada ça
bouge pas trop ça fait juste que grossir
en volume comme ça canal qui ressemble à
un peu des spaghettis physarum en fait
il fait partie d'une famille qui
s'appelle les fuites d'arrivée est donc
là vous avez trouvé tous les blocs sur
laquelle nous on travaille pas d'avenir
au frigo c'est tous ces blogs ne
s'intéresse surtout aux blocs qui sont
rapides entre guinée ce qui se déplace
vraiment oui quel sentiment
quelques centimètres par ailleurs cela
s'est intéressé très fin et c'est le
fait ça mais en vrai ces quelques
millimètres
les éleveurs pour le dire ou alors twist
ghost disait vous parliez de 2,20 tout à
l'heure c'est des veines mais ça il n'y
a pas de sens le loonie n'a pas parcouru
200 non c'est un cytoplasme c'est le
liquide intracellulaire et c'est un
liquide transportent les noyaux les
organites de la cellule des nutriments
et les gaz donc c'est un peu la fonction
du sens mais c'est pas du sang à
proprement parler et donc dans ses
veines ce liquide y circulant à quelques
millimètres secondes si vous le mettez
sous une loupe binoculaire donc vous
mettez même une petite place sinon même
une petite plaque de type la clède vous
savez pour des tablettes pour dessiner
la vous pouvez le voir en fait ce flux
se déplacer parce que ça se voit
vraiment l'oeil nu quelques l'univers
par seconde et on voit que c'est très
rigolo vous avez le plus donc ça va dans
une direction que ça ralentit comme ça
et hop ça repart dans l'autre sens parce
que le blog c'est comme ça qu'il avance
c'est comme un système de maréis pousse
son site aux places me contre la
membrane est il le reprend il repousse
vraiment comme quand vous poussez sur un
tube de dentifrice et votre dentifrice
et solide avance et c'est comme ça que
d'avancer un système très particulier à
ce système comme hydraulique pour se
déplacer il ya plusieurs heures un
camion qui demandent si on ose avait un
effet de la musique sur la musique du
site et ont pas vraiment mais par contre
le blog fait de la musique
chercheur peau en angleterre c'est dans
le film ça qu'à connecter le blog avec
des électrodes et la musique du globo
ces voix la musique c'est conceptuel
ouais ouais c'est en fait la saison
c'est synchroniser sur les rythmes dans
les veines et comme elles sont toutes
des synchroniser ses chroniques oui
parce que chez nous le sang circule dans
un seul sens parce qu'ils auraient des
problèmes dans le blog c'est pas le cas
alors à l'intérieur de ces verbes ce que
vous disiez assez sec ce qui fait ce que
nous mène de reptation un petit peu on
appelle ça l'effet navette
c'est vraiment un aller retour qu'ils
aient toutes les 60 secondes me change
de sens et quand il veut aller dans une
direction ce qui fait c'est qui il
pousse pas en 70 secondes en un sens
c'est 50 dans l'autre finalement ça
finit par avancer dans la direction dans
laquelle ils veulent et à et toutes les
veines en fait le sens de circulation il
est vraiment qui peu indépendance dans
quelque chose de poser quelle zone du
globe retrouve donc c'est très compliqué
à comprendre
il ya beaucoup beaucoup de biophysicien
et c'est vraiment décide qu on commencé
vers ce point dans sa marche à
l'intérieur et ça reste un mystère même
si c'est un organisme créé c'est lui il
est très compliqué alors il ya les eris
qui pose la question vous parlez de quel
film en fait c'est un documentaire
réalisé par jacques mitsch en
collaboration avec audrey dussutour un
pour tous tous cas ce scientifique
x documente le blob un cerveau sedan un
génie sans cerveau génie de sa chérie
c'est ça et c'est un documentaire qui
est maintenant sur la chaîne youtube
d'arte et écouter audrey dussutour on a
dépassé les les 6000 c'est pas de samuel
etienne mais c'est quand même pas être
être contents nous audrey dussutour ou
qu'on la dit tout à l'heure à un moment
vous avez d'abord travaillé le moment
sur les fourmis une question qui est
maintenant complètement laissé de côté
dans votre carrière
un petit peu en ce moment parce que on a
on a déménagé dans un nouveau bâtiment
et j'ai pas beaucoup de place pour
travailler sur les deux organismes j'ai
dû faire un peu des choix est donc pour
l'instant je laisse et les fourmis mais
vraiment c'est c'est provisoire de côté
je lui ai encore comme des étudiants qui
travaillent avec moi mais à l'étranger
sur les fourmis ça va jusqu'à mon coeur
de métier d'or les fourmis c'est
vraiment c'est passionnant et c'est un
petit peu parce que j'ai vu la question
passé dans le blog serré dans le nord
c'est quoi la la la la la similarité la
civilité par les fourmis et leur y en a
une en fait c'est une fascine chez ces
deux organismes c'est la façon dont ils
arrivent à résoudre des problèmes de
façon un petit peu distribué
centralisation d'un cerveau chez les
fourmis on sait qu'à une intelligence
collective
quand vous mettez beaucoup de fournir
semble derrière faire des choses
incroyables qu'elles sont pas forcément
capables de faire de manière
individuelle nokia pas un leader chez
fond c'est ce qu'on appelle l'auto
organisation et chez le blog c'est aussi
aux petits poteaux organisé et donc moi
c'est ce qui me fascine chez ces deux
organismes la façon de finalement de
résoudre des problèmes et complètement
différente de la nôtre
ils sont dans un système hyper
hiérarchisé avec des leaders des
capitaines des commandes chez les
fourmis a pas sa petite troupe
d'anarchistes et pourtant ça fonctionne
hyper bien développe aussi c'est un
petit peu d'anarchistes donc c'est ça
qu'on perd un peu j'essaie de faire 4 mm
et les anarchistes vous vous voulez
aller à sa rencontre et déjà une
question là dessus
ah oui et ça c'était forcément re s'est
dit est ce que pour cycles et le blob et
de personnages est quand même la moitié
des blogs tous les jours
lorsque les fourmis pouvaient le manger
c'est très carré de chouettes et dans
les fourmis en détester le blog we know
plus vraiment
ils sont chacun restés de leur côté on
adore par le devine qu on a une vidéo où
il ya des fourmis qui sont en train de
manger un champignon et seront chassés
par louis le bloc vient société nant
donc le blog c'est plutôt un solitaire
quoi il a besoin d'un solitaire mais il
communique un peu ils communiquent mais
j'ai vu la question passé ce qui est un
système de communication par le bloc
communiqué son stress à ses congénères
un blog est stressé ça fait une
expansion après une dernière quand un
blog est stressé sur l'empoisonnent si
on ira vite de la lumière il peut
sécréter des molécules dans le normand
qui vont dire aux autres blogs
venez pas par là c'est super dangereux
les deux blocs sont détectés ces
molécules et partant la direction
opposée
donc il communique un petit peu un tout
petit peu mais c'est pas c'est pas un
être social en le parce que si vous
coupez votre blog open petits morceaux
d'avoir fusionné pour former une unique
bloc dont vous avez toujours qu'un blog
et quand ils sont de simples d'origine
géographique différente on a le blog
australien qui aime beaucoup ses
congénères vie colle tout le monde et on
a le blog américain qui est un peu moins
sociale la social du groupe qui va
toujours chercher à éviter les autres
voilà comme comme on fait pas de
généralités sur alors il est 19h écouter
on en est arrivé ccc ccc leur la fin de
notre direct
1c'est de presse de jean castex
d'ailleurs d'affaires à 18 heures mais
il faut aller au bout de notre twitter
officiel tous être là avec l'eau c'était
passionnant audrey dussutour
enthousiasme a été comment célébrée par
plusieurs commentaires sur ce sur ce sur
ce chat
je rappelle que vous êtes l'auteur de
tout ce que vous avez toujours comme ça
voire sans jamais oser le demander si en
livre de poche
c'est vrai à buca super parce que ça
parle du blog mais sa part de la science
la science telle qu'on la pratique
aujourd'hui c'est un livre très
sympathique c'est à dire que il ya
beaucoup de vous enfin je vous connais
pas on se connaît pas c'était prévu
avant mais c'est très sympathique enfin
moi j'ai beaucoup aimé lui le balancier
navale anti delattre vidéastes de 2,2 me
youtube science poire une prochaine
vidéo peut-être qu arrive oui
à très bientôt sur la très bientôt sur
la structure interne de la terre
gentil pas plus avec lui sexistes ou
offrir non c'est à dire que peut-être
que vous pourrez mettre un blog c4 dans
une de vos vidéos
c'est une idée tant qu elle il est bon
mais écoutez merci merci à tous je
rappelle que le dernier sciences et
avenir étant clos ce qui fait sa
couverture sur l'hydrogène la solution
hydrogène on a aussi le trimestriel la
recherche conçues par une cascade comme
belmondo au lard et donc la recherche
le trimestriel l'origine du vivant c'est
aussi en kiosque merci à tous mais avoir
été sinon merci audrey d'avoir
vulgariser aussi bien le sujet est
complexe et intéressant nous dit as
robox voilà merci beaucoup
merci à tout le monde a l'air content
mais c'est génial on se retrouve et le
bolter essor c'est l'effet bloc mais pas
le blog sous cocaïne donc on a compris
donc on se retrouve à 17h30
hall a semaine prochaine sur la chaîne
c'est à venir écouter abonnez-vous à
partager l'info dit que si on sait à
venir et sur twitch ça nous fera merci a
bientot merci
[Musique]